look how beautiful you look
thank you
all right thank you yeah because I do
have a Joanna voice you have a Johnny
voice and a Joanna voice yeah this is
Johnny voice and this is Joanna voice so
hi how's it going this is Joanna it's
much more lighter yeah
um yeah but for me I enjoy both I enjoy
being Johnny and I enjoy being Johanna
which one do you
relate to more it's really hard
um
I guess it's almost like
you know if you're playing a video game
and you're picking stats it's like okay
what's what's the best stat you know um
for me I enjoy
being masculine I enjoy being feminine
um
you know they're they're both
captivating to me they're even the
extreme Parts I enjoy extreme femininity
and I enjoy extreme masculinity is there
a sexual element to one or the other yes
but it it's not always sexual even
though yeah it can be sexual
your sexual encounters are more when you
are dressed as Joanna
yeah but
honestly my encounters are mostly fetish
rather than sexual what are your
fetishes
uh bondage diapers
um
yeah just you know just to start your
diaper lover they call it yeah so
there's this thing called abdl
what does that stand for
uh it stands for adult baby diaper lover
and for me I stand mostly on the diaper
lover side
and that's something that I felt as a
kid and I never had any traumatic
experience
experience to have that
but
sometimes I dwell on the
adult baby side
sometimes I enjoy pacifiers sometimes I
enjoy
dressing up in little clothes and so it
that's why they call it abdl it's so
clever how they found out about that
meaning what
as in like I'm not sure so it's been
around maybe since like the 90s I'm not
sure who who coined the term abdl but
it's been around
um you don't think anything happened to
you when you were six years old or
whatever
surprisingly now or maybe you don't
remember
perhaps I mean you know perhaps because
a grown man doesn't
develop a fetish for wearing diapers
out of nothing I don't think well I've
had this fetish when I was four or five
years old and I remember one of my
earliest memories was to
have the urge to where my younger
brother's diapers
and then when I did I was in the
bathroom and then my mom caught me and
then I was so ashamed and so afraid
and you know I just kept you know kept
crying and you know just like hiding the
diaper behind my back and she insisted
to show her what I had
um I'm not sure what happened after that
but that was one of my earliest memories
tell me about your childhood you had mom
and dad
yeah I was raised by my mom and dad
um but you know
when I was in fourth grade
they split up
how would you describe your relationship
with your mom and your dad
my dad lives in Mexico
my mom lives here and she
has a house here and I love him very
much
and so yeah um contrary to
other ways of it being abdl
I'm very fortunate to have my experience
to be non-traumatic
and still be attracted to abdom
and if there was like I'm trying to like
search through my
um my memories to see if there was but
like I never had this really traumatic
experience so the only one that I had
was like just wanting to try my younger
brother's diapers
how old are you now
31 31 and you you're working yeah
what do you do for work just in a
general
I do a lot of things
um one is a as a substitute teacher
right now I just picked up a job as a
you know I.T technician
and so I just have a very various amount
of jobs
another job is that you know me my
um
my dad or my stepdad you know founded um
a really really small painting company
and just me and him
and so I just I just like having these
odd you know odd jobs that you know pay
my bills and the cross-dressing comes in
when like weekends or evenings or you
know I started cross-dressing do you
mind if I tell you when I started
cross-dressing sure yeah so I had no
previous experience of cross-dressing
until I was
29 which was uh which was the beginning
of the pandemic there was no pandemic I
would would have not started
cross-dressing
so it was from 2020
when I started cross-dressing in October
the pandemic gets the credit for your
cross-dressing honestly yeah that and
and a lot of other factors
but
but since yeah it was it was the
ultimate Factor but there were other
factors in terms of yeah like I was
asking
um
these girls out and they were they were
not interested in me
and there were girls that were attracted
to me but I was not interested in them
so it just felt like this game of like
you know um no one's getting anywhere
romantically you are attracted to males
or females uh females emails
yeah so I think it's kind of an oddity
that
I am a straight crossdresser but
honestly there there's I think it's more
common than people think
starting to get that feeling so many
especially here in San Francisco so many
oh yes there's so many men that are
trying to be women yeah yeah and yeah
more part to them you know
you're happier as Joanna
I've thought more comfortable Maybe
it's a different experience
and it's almost it's almost like
um
imagine your most masculine self the
most masculine thing you've ever
experienced and being part of that
and imagine your most feminine
experience and being part of that it's
so like I guess for me I get to
experience both
um but but in the female side it's in a
sense not as true because you know but
but in the sense
what boys don't
most likely won't will experience it is
the I
um
the experience of in a sense being
beautiful
so for as a guy they what girls won't
experience is
being powerful
because mostly that sun has a man you
know as a man you know um
doing heavy lifting stuff
but as a female uh
as a female they could achieve beauty
that man can never have
and so it's two opposite sides of a coin
and I enjoy both and I think it's
the beauty of life or you know whatever
you want to call it
you can enjoy beautiful women
you can enjoy the company of beautiful
women rather than trying to be one
I just felt um I was never good at that
you know for some reason I was um you
know I did what what I was supposed to
do as a man you know
yeah
graduated from University even though I
don't like to hold
degrees to a pedestal
but but I did was what I was supposed to
do as a man
but I I was just never able to attract
the humor that I wanted and so for me
this is my response I do a lot of Art
and so my response was like Hey like why
not just make myself into the female
that I was desired and you know maybe it
may not show up in this
um video but
it you know um it's always a
it's always a practice that's learned
and and from yeah for me like eventually
like yeah I was comfortable
I I enjoyed the way Joanna looks
as Johnny
and you've had romantic relationships
yeah just two uh when I was younger
I had my first girlfriend and it was
only a month and I kind of let go of
that relationship because her mother was
really controlling and it just didn't
make sense in my mind to be in a
relationship you know uh
we went to the movies and I had to
invite her mom so that was funny
um but it just felt like her mom was you
know had her hands at that girl that I
was dating and we eventually became
boyfriend and girlfriend but I had to
call it off because there was no time to
see each other so it just didn't make
any sense
it sounds like some of the stems from
your frustration about being able to
attract the kind of woman you want yeah
and to be honest it does but for me like
I have uh I'm not bitter about that you
know because I just feel like everyone
should be allowed to love who they love
and
I feel like I have a purpose I do
believe in God and you know I I listen
to God I listen to the universe I listen
to what I should do in life and I always
try to do right you know I I know as
human beings you know we're full of sin
but we just try to do what's right you
describe yourself as a good person
that's not up to me that I guess that's
up to God's inside and um honestly yeah
um I I don't think anyone
who can say they're a good person you
know we're all for the sin
we could try to be a good person
[Music]
what was your favorite memory from your
childhood
um
I think just having dinner with my mom
hanging out with my dad
the the closest that we had and having
people
around yeah because
um my parents
yeah my mom was the first one to
from our family to go into the United
States
and I was the first one to be born in
the United States
and I guess I never really saw
you know what my life would have been if
I was born in Mexico because my parents
are from Mexico
but but I do remember like you know
having a lot of parties and just
having a good time with with family
members which I don't see now which I
feel like it's
kind of upsetting you know I feel like
we don't connect you know as much as we
did before
do you have friends
yeah very few very few but yeah
you had your life to live over again
would you have done anything differently
no I think there's a purpose to what we
did even though the bad stuff and the
upsetting stuff
um so I'm really grateful I'm really
grateful to where I'm right now and yeah
even though like um
if you had uh told me 10 years ago that
I would have
cross-dressed
I would have told you to like you know
stfilia you know shut the [__] up
because I never expected to do this and
this is just something that I I kind of
uh did out of response of what I was
going through I just felt isolated
is it hard being Latino Latina and
being a cross-dresser
not specifically
I I think we all go through
our own
troubles
so I don't think specifically that
um yeah I think we just have our own
unique experiences
emotionally how would you describe
yourself do you go through
about the depression or anxiety or
things like that you know when I was
younger I used to have
seasonal depression when it was the
winter I I just and I couldn't figure
out why but I just felt like really sad
well even when I was a kid I just felt
like sad and that's why when I dress as
Joanna I mean yeah like my social media
handles are um
sad girl Joanna
yeah because in a sense I do have a sad
soul I'm not sure what that means but I
could kind of try to explain
it's really complicated
but
it's been the most difficult time of
your life
that's a good question um
I think we all go through difficult
times
I think more most recently just because
um
yeah a few months ago I wasn't able to
pay the bills and I felt everything was
hopeless
but um I think that's
when I was a kid
um
my parents went through
a Christmas with you know like no like
almost no food no gifts and they just
kind of had to like you know but but I
didn't realize it because I was a kid
and so I guess that that should have
been you know the most
hard but you know by my parents had a
good parents that um
kind of um
I didn't even know it until they told me
after when I was older what do you do
for fun no as an adult
I like
making music
I produce music
I like to watch things on YouTube where
they explain how things work
I like to go to Parks I like to run
I like to watch movies but just like you
know
movies that you know were
were they had intents not just any kind
of movie you know we're like yeah okay
there was there was a purpose
to this kind of movie and how often will
you dress as a as Joanna
it can vary sometimes it'll be zero
times a week sometimes at the most Maybe
four or five times a week
I think during the month it could be
around
you know
10 through 15.
yeah the end
sometimes I'll be public sometimes I'll
just stay at home so it just really
depends
what's your biggest fear
what do you worry about
for me I mean
the biggest fear maybe could be that
uh
asteroid wipes is all so it's like so I
mean for me like I'm thinking the worst
of the worst you know
yeah I mean I guess maybe maybe even
losing a loved one
you know but um
you know I pray to God every day and
what's your greatest strength
to just be sensible
you just have common sense
to not take sides and to just think look
at things objectively
because I feel people you know um are so
one-sided
Joanna what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
I would worry about what are people
gonna think when they see this there are
some things about myself that have to be
expressed so I just have to learn to be
more honest
all right Johnny Joanna thank you so
much for sharing your story
I wish you the best of luck thank you